a big breaking story this afternoon
after less than a day of deliberations
the jury reached a guilty verdict on all
three charges in the murder trial of
former police officer derrick chauvin
good afternoon thank you for joining us
at four o'clock i'm kirsten joyce and
i'm christian casadas for nearly a month
now all eyes have been
on minneapolis watching this trial
unfold we want to head right out to
michael george who's been tracking it
all for us
the jury in the derrick chauvin murder
trial has found him guilty of
all charges we the jury in the above
entitled matter has to count one
unintentional second degree murder while
committing a felony find the defendant
guilty
outside the courthouse people reacted to
the verdict
i am so grateful to god i'm so happy i'm
so glad we got this we needed this
the country needed this the world needed
this it's not a black-and-white issue
it's a human rights issue and we need to
see change former minneapolis police
officer derek chovin was facing charges
for killing george floyd
when he knelt on his neck for more than
nine minutes last may
the jury reviewed three weeks of
testimony from 45 witnesses
in one of the most closely watched
murder trials in american history
the jury took less than a full day to
reach its verdict
michael george cbs news minneapolis